- Russia has invaded Ukraine,
and many are calling this "an
illegal war of aggression".
But what does it mean
for a war to be illegal?
What does international
law mean in this context?
And what is even international law itself?
Because the recent Russian
invasion of Ukraine
has shocked and horrified
people all around the world.
Almost every nation has
condemned the invasion,
many calling it "an illegal war".
Even traditionally neutral
countries like Switzerland
and Sweden have joined in
economic sanctions against Russia.
And the Secretary General
of the United Nations
concluded that Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
violated international law, saying, quote,
"It is wrong, it is against
the United Nations Charter.
It is unacceptable."
The United Nations Charter,
which has been affirmed
by 193 member states, says that countries
should not invade each other.
But what happens next comes down to this,
who, if anyone, has the authority
to enforce international law,
and how are you going to
stop an invading force?
(bright music)
Law professor Louis Henkin,
who is credited founding the
study of human rights law,
famously wrote that, quote,
"Almost all nations observe
almost all principles
of international law,
and almost all of their
obligations, almost all the time."
Henkin's observation was
that in the modern world,
most countries agree on
the general standards
of international conduct.
However, the troubles arise
because of the word, "almost."
What about when nations don't agree
with international standards of conduct,
or just simply don't observe them?
Do these international
standards have the force of law?
Does the international
community have the ability
to enforce its standards of conduct?
Well, today we're going to
talk about international law.
What it is, what it isn't
and what happens next in Ukraine.
But first some background on
Russian and Ukrainian history.
Now, this is a very complicated subject,
I'm only going to scratch the surface,
but I think this will be helpful.
From 1922 until 1991, Ukraine was a member
of the Soviet Union.
But in 1991, it declared its independence
and became its own sovereign state.
In 2004, the Orange Revolution led
to annulling a presidential election
which was claimed to be
marred by massive corruption,
voter intimidation, and electoral fraud.
New elections were held in 2005
that eventually led to Viktor Yushchenko
beating the Russian-backed
Viktor Yanukovych.
But Yanukovych eventually
succeeded in the 2010 election.
But in 2013, the Ukrainian people
launched a protest movement
against the corrupt pro-Russian
president Viktor Yanukovych,
who was seen as being backed
by Russian billionaires
who were hostile to NATO.
Not to make this about the United States,
but coincidentally, during this era,
Donald Trump's campaign
manager, Paul Manafort
spent 10 years as one of
Yanukovych's advisors.
Of course in 2020, President
Trump was impeached
by the House after he
put on hold $391 million
in congressionally improved
military aid to Ukraine.
But in 2013, Ukraine's government
was about to sign an agreement
establishing closer ties
with Europe, but Yanukovych
backed out one week
before the agreement was to be signed.
Instead, he announced that Ukraine
would build a stronger
relationship with Russia.
This announcement reneged
on a campaign promise
and Yanukovych's popularity plummeted.
And after the Euromaidan protests,
Yanukovych fled to Russia
and Ukraine's elected a
pro-Western government.
And in 2014, Russia tried to hack
Ukraine Central Election Commission
so that it would present
a far right candidate,
who in fact, got less than
1% of the vote as the winner.
As historian Tim Snyder
documented, "the hack failed
but Russian media had been
prepared for its success
and Russian television went on air
with falsified documents,
even digital images
that matched what the hack
was supposed to produce."
When the election gambit
failed, Russia invaded Ukraine
and annexed the territory of Crimea.
And in 2019, former comedian
Volodymyr Zelenskyy,
who on TV, played a
history teacher who ran
on an anti-corruption platform,
and eventually became
the president of Ukraine,
ran on an anti-corruption platform
and became the president of Ukraine.
And of course, prior to
this most recent invasion,
Zelenskyy was famous in the United States
for having what everyone
called a perfect phone call
with former president, Donald Trump.
Just an absolutely perfect phone call.
Then in February of 2022,
Russian president Vladimir Putin
launched a full scale war on Ukraine,
claiming that he needed
to limit Nazism in Ukraine
and that he was defending the people
of the Donbas regions of Ukraine.
The international community
recognized that Donbas,
like Crimea, is part of Ukraine.
So the question is, is
this an illegal war?
And what does it even
mean to be an illegal war
under international law?
Well, I'm sorry to tell you,
it probably doesn't mean all that much.
So the phrase "international
law" is a bit of a misnomer
because international
law isn't really binding
in the way that American
laws generally are.
In America, the primary sources of law
are the US Constitution,
laws enacted by Congress,
rules promulgated by federal agencies,
state constitutions, laws
enacted by state legislatures,
rules promulgated by state agencies,
and city or county
Charters and local laws.
And as see, there's generally
a hierarchy to these laws.
Statutes and rules can't
contradict a higher source of law.
For example, the US Constitution
is generally at the top of that list.
And a state law or a state constitution
that contradicts the federal constitution
where state law is supreme
is considered void.
But in contrast, there isn't really
an international hierarchy of law.
Sovereign nations may agree on
general principles of conduct
but there isn't a body
of international law
that is superior to
their own national laws.
So the first thing you need to know
about international laws is
that everything is dependent
on the individual states,
and as you can imagine,
individual sovereign
nations are incredibly
reluctant to give up any of their autonomy
and to subject themselves
to the potential whims
of other countries.
United States is no exception to this.
So what do we mean when we
talk about international law?
Well, the most important sources
of international law are customary
international law derived
from practice of the states,
treaties between the states
and general principles of law,
recognized by civilized nations.
Now, the oldest source of
what we call international law
tends to be customary international law.
And this doesn't really
have a written source
like a criminal code.
Instead, it's more like English Common Law
since it's made up of unwritten rules
that are derived from custom and practice.
A rule of customary law has two elements.
First, there has to be widespread
and consistent state practice.
The practice must be by the government
but must also be recognized
by the state's courts and parliament.
And second, there has to be
what's called opinio juris,
which is the state's belief
that it has a legal obligation.
What's an example of
customary international law?
Well diplomatic immunity, for example.
Diplomatic immunity is
a principle that gives
certain foreign government officials
the right to safe passage
through other countries,
guaranteeing the diplomat cannot be sued
or arrested for violating
the host country's law.
This principle of diplomatic immunity
is one of the oldest
elements of foreign relations
observed in ancient
Greece and Rome sometimes.
Now prior to World War
II, countries recognized
diplomatic immunity based
simply on precedent.
But after World War
II, diplomatic immunity
was embedded in a number of
international conventions.
And today, all countries
agree that diplomats
have diplomatic immunity,
although they can be
expelled from their host
countries for violating the law.
Then we can talk about treaties.
Treaties are a second
source of international law.
An international treaty
is a written agreement
international law subjects
reflecting their consent
to the creation, alteration or termination
of their rights and obligations.
Treaties may also be called agreements,
conventions or protocols.
Now, a treaty is not
the same thing as a law.
A treaty is a source of an obligation
under the law and
treaties are only binding
on states which agree to
become parties to them.
So there is no international tribunal
or government that can
force any sovereign nation
to become a party to a treaty
against that nation's will.
And so if there's no government
or court that can compel states to join
or comply with a treaty, why
are treaties binding at all?
Well, generally because
of a customary principle
of international law
called pacta sunt servada.
which is Latin for
"agreements must be kept".
And I greatly apologize for all
of my mispronounced Latin
throughout this entire video.
As it turns out, it's really
hard to speak a dead language.
Now, all states recognize
that they are bound
by the agreements that they make
and therefore, they are
obligated to honor their treaties
but sometimes a treaty will
memorialize a principle
of customary law, in essence,
codifying a general
understanding between nations.
For example, the 1969 Vienna Convention
on the Law of Treaties codified
the basic customary principles
governing international treaties.
The Vienna Convention is
known as the treaty on treaty.
And in the US, for example,
a treaty only becomes binding
if Congress agrees that
it should become binding
and effectively, the law
of the United States.
So again, it's about the
consent of the governed.
And if a country wants
to back out of a treaty,
there's effectively nothing
that any other country can do.
But then that takes us
to general principles
of civilized nations.
These are general principles
of fairness and justice
which are applied universally
in legal systems around the world.
And although that sounds pretty sweeping,
in reality, these principles
are pretty much gap fillers.
When there's a dispute
and there is no provision
in an international treaty or statute
or any recognized customary
principle of international law,
the general principles of law
can be used to fill the gaps.
An example of that would be the admission
of indirect evidence.
In 1949, an International
Court of Justice decision
addressed whether Albania
had civil liability
for the mining of the Corfu Channel
and subsequent damage to
two British Naval vessels.
The court rule that the UK
could establish the knowledge
and responsibility of Albania
for laying mines in the water
through indirect evidence
since indirect evidence is admitted
in basically all systems of law.
And then of course, there are other
sort of miscellaneous
sources of international law
that may help resolve
international disputes.
You can look to court decisions,
writings by international lawyers
and actions taken by the United Nations
and it's many organs.
But you can imagine that
if the prior sources
of international law aren't binding,
these certainly are not
going to have that much
of a presidential effect.
Now I'm sure many people
are watching this video
and screaming at the screen,
"What about the United Nations?"
Well, the United Nations was established
after World War II to provide a formal way
for nations of the world to communicate
and resolve disputes.
The Charter of the United Nations
is an international treaty
that commits member states
to settle their disputes
by peaceful means.
Many people have the
mistaken impression though
that the UN General
Assembly is the government
of the whole world.
However, the United
Nations General Assembly
has no power to legislate for
the international community.
Its resolutions are not legally binding.
The General Assembly cannot
enact international laws
and then force member states
to submit to its authority.
UN resolutions do influence
international relations
but they're not the equivalent
of laws and statutes.
So that's the United
Nations General Assembly,
but what about the UN Security Council?
And in fact, the UN Security Council
is the only international
body that has the power
to make binding decisions on all nations.
The council has 15 members.
The five permanent members
are China, France, Russia
the United Kingdom and the United States.
And it also has 10 non-permanent members
whose terms run for two years.
Each member has one vote.
And in 2022, the temporary members
of the Security Council are
the United Arab Emirates,
Albania, Brazil, Gabon,
Ghana, India, Ireland,
Kenya, Mexico, and Norway.
The five permanent members
all have veto power
over all UN Security Council matters.
And under the Charter
of the United Nations
all member states are obligated to comply
with Council decisions.
Therefore, decisions by
the UN Security Council
aren't considered legally binding.
Quote under Chapter VII, "The
council can take measures
to enforce decisions and ensure
that mandates are fulfilled.
The Security Council can
impose economic sanctions
or order an arms embargo,
and on rare occasions,
the Council has authorized member states
to use all necessary means,
including collective military action
to see that its decisions
are carried out."
All member states are
obligated under the UN Charter
to carry out the Security
Council's decision.
Now, all of the world is remarkably United
about Russia's war against Ukraine,
it will still be difficult
if not impossible
for the Security Council
to take direct action against Russia.
Most Security Councils
decisions require a majority
of the nine members plus consent
of all five permanent member states.
Russia, a permanent, member
vetoed a Council resolution
condemning its attack on Ukraine.
China and India and the
United Arab Emirates
abstained from that vote.
But you can imagine that as long as Russia
is a member of the UN Security Council,
no resolution is going to pass.
Though I will say there is an interesting
legal movement gaining some traction,
which says that Russia
is in fact not a member
of the UN Security Council.
Effectively, the argument goes like this.
The original member of
the UN Security Council
was the Soviet Union and
the Soviet Union collapsed.
Though it was succeeded
by the Russian Federation,
Russia just assumed that
it took over the spot
that was originally created for the USSR.
So some argue that without
formalizing this relationship
with Russia, Russia does not hold the seat
that the former Soviet union
held on the Security Council.
This seems a little bit farfetched,
but we'll see if it gains
traction in the future.
But let's take a moment to talk
about the use of force
under international law.
After the devastation of two World Wars,
United Nations was born.
The UN Charter established a prohibition
on the use of force to
resolve disputes among states.
Article 2, Section 4 of
the Charter bans the threat
or use of force, one, against
the territorial integrity
of a state, two, against
the political independence
of a state and three, in any other manner
inconsistent with the purposes of the UN.
Now, with that said,
there are two exceptions
to the prohibition on the use of force.
The Security Council can use force
on behalf of the UN to
maintain peace and security.
A member state can also use self-defense
to repel an armed attack.
Chapter VI of the UN Charter establishes
that force may be used to the peace
if the Security Council determines
that there is the existence
of a threat to the peace,
a breach of the piece
or an act of aggression
and efforts to address
the matter using measures
short of force have
failed or would be futile.
Now, in the early days of
the UN, the Charter suggested
that all member states
would make their military
and resources collectively available
to the Security Council
to use to stop wars.
But this has effectively
never materialized.
And as a result, when the Council needs
a peacekeeping force, willing states
volunteer their personnel.
Putin tried to take
advantage of this exception
by declaring that his forces
were a peacekeeping force
and former president Trump
thought this was a great idea
and suggested that the
us should invade Mexico
with fake peacekeeping forces as well.
Of course, this is not
what peacekeeping means.
Under the UN Charter as one source put it,
"The Security Council takes the lead
in determining the existence of a threat
to the peace or an act of aggression.
It calls upon the parties
to a dispute to settle
it by peaceful means
and recommends methods of
adjustment or terms of settlement.
Under Chapter VII of the UN Charter,
the Security Council can
take enforcement measures
to maintain or restore
international peace and security.
Such measures range
from economic sanctions
to international military action.
The Council also establishes
UN Peacekeeping Operations
and Special Political Missions."
Now, additionally, Article
51 of the UN Charter
provides for self-defense, quote,
"Nothing in the present
Charter shall impair
the inherent right of individual
or collective self-defense
if armed attack occurs against a member
of the United Nations
until the Security Council
has taken measures necessary to maintain
international peace and security."
Sovereign nation's right of self-defense
predates international organizations,
and it's one of the fundamental principles
of state sovereignty.
And as part of this
right, nations can rescue
their own citizens who
are trapped or being held
in another country, but
a nation can't claim
it's merely protecting its own citizens
if its real aim is to
overthrow a foreign government.
Now, Russian president Putin said
that people in the Donbas
Republics sought Russia's help
and that qualifies as self-defense.
But Article 51 lines to
states not to individuals.
So as of now, Russia is the only state
that has recognized the
two Donbas Republics
as their own nations,
though this claim appears
to be pretext for invasion.
And although Putin claims
that the Ukrainians
are committing genocide in the Donbas,
this also appears to be a pretext as well.
And Russia also claims that
Ukraine is the aggressor here,
but even after or the invasion of Crimea,
Ukraine did not invade or
really even threaten Russia.
So is the war in Ukraine
illegal under international law?
Well, yes, but the
principle that war's illegal
is only as strong as the
international community's
willingness to intervene in the conflict.
And the first modern
attempt to make war illegal
was in 1928, when the
US and France created
the Kellogg-Briand Pact,
where dozens of countries
joined the treaty which called on nations
to settle their disputes peacefully.
This treaty was only as good
as its members' commitment to it.
And of course, the pact meant nothing
when World War II erupted a decade later.
The world tried again in 1949
with the Geneva Conventions.
The Geneva Conventions
govern how civilians,
prisoners of war and soldiers are treated.
You've probably heard that
the Geneva Conventions
prohibit nations from torturing people
or using torture to extract information.
And effectively, all nations have joined
the Geneva Conventions, but
these treaties only govern
how people are treated during war,
they don't say anything
about the legality of the war itself.
And even though the
Security Council actions
are said to be binding,
they're only binding
if the Council actually
choose to enforce them.
For example, the
Iran-Iraq War in the 1980s
clearly violated the laws of war
but the Security Council
took no steps to intervene.
And then finally, perhaps most importantly
there is the international Criminal Court.
Now, the ICC is an independent
judicial institution
that was established in 2002.
It is empowered to investigate
and prosecute war crimes,
crimes against humanity, genocide
and the crime of aggression.
123 countries are ICC members,
which means that these
countries have given the ICC
the authority to investigate
and prosecute crimes
committed by their nations or
by anyone on their territory.
The ICC doesn't have
the power over countries
that aren't a party to
the treaty, however.
And the US, for example,
did not join the ICC.
President Clinton signed the Rome Statute,
the treaty authorizing the ICC,
but the Senate wouldn't ratify it.
And president George W. Bush
then unsigned the treaty,
informing the UN that
America did not recognize
any obligations under the ICC.
Nevertheless, US citizens
can still be prosecuted
for committing war crimes if it happens
in a territory that is an ICC member.
Afghanistan, for example,
is a party to the ICC
and can request that the
ICC investigate Americans
for committing war crimes,
but at the same time,
the ICC cannot override the
laws of any sovereign nation.
It only exercises its
jurisdiction when a country
is either unwilling or
genuinely unable to investigate
and prosecute war crimes.
And of course, countries
are free to prosecute
war crimes in their own courts.
Though, that being said,
neither Russia nor Ukraine
have signed or adopted the Rome Treaty
and are not members of the ICC.
So Russia cannot be prosecuted
for the crime of aggression.
However, in 2014, after
Russia annexed Crimea,
Ukraine submitted a declaration
giving the ICC jurisdiction
for crimes committed any
time on it's property
after February, 2014.
So Ukraine can ask that
ICC prosecutors open
a full investigation
into Russia's actions.
Now, I know when we
cover international law,
it often feels like there's
nothing that we can do
but that's not true,
and in fact, if you'd like to
do some good for this world,
especially regarding Ukraine,
I'd recommend Tab for a Cause,
which is helpfully sponsoring this video.
Now, Tab for a Cause lets you raise money
for charity just by
opening tabs and browsing
the internet, which we are
probably gonna do, anyway.
And in fact, Tab for a Cause responded
to your request and they have an entire
Ukraine-specific page
geared towards providing
essential services and
supplies to Ukrainian families.
And in fact, Save the
Children has been providing
ongoing humanitarian aid
in Ukraine since 2014
and will continue to support families,
even if, fingers-crossed,
the conflict ends soon.
Now Tab for a Cause is a
Google Chrome Extension
that allows you to pick
the charity of your choice,
and then every time you open up a new tab,
instead of displaying a blank page,
it displays a beautiful new customized tab
with a couple of tiny ads.
Now, the money that you generate
through those open pages
is then donated to your charity.
Tab for a Cause has partnered
with Save the Children,
which is mobilizing now
for the Ukrainian people.
And Tab for a Cause's finances
are completely transparent.
You can see for yourself how
much money they've raised
every quarter and where
that money has gone.
And believe it or not the LegalEagles,
the people like you who
are watching my videos
have already raised over
$35,000 alone for charity
just by opening tabs, and
I'm really thankful for that.
So all you have to do is click on the link
that's on screen right
now or in the description
and install the Chrome extension.
That's it.
Every page you open will create revenue
that goes to charity and
it's completely free.
Tab for a Cause users like
you raised millions of dollars
and it's the easiest possible
way to donate to charity.
So just click on the link below
and download the extension
and do some good by doing
what you were gonna do anyway.
So click on that link or
I'll see you in court.